hey youtubers is Charlie huge news
Marvel just confirmed a whole bunch of
people for thor ragnarok so this is
going to be a breakdown of what's going
on let's start with the biggest stuff
first hulk is confirmed to be in the
movie Bruce Banner
so we'll get a version of Planet Hulk
inside a Thor movie I think I've already
explained why they can't do a hulk solo
film it has to do with the distribution
rights universal really it's like a
behind the scenes thing it's not because
Marvel doesn't want to make a Hulk movie
but the next best thing is doing one of
the best Hulk stories Planet Hulk inside
of a Thor movie so if you've read Planet
Hulk or if you've seen the animated
movie there'll be a version of those
things happening inside the store movie
if you have absolutely no idea what
Planet Hulk is just think Hulk
Thunderdome two people enter one Hulk
leaves as expected Kate Blanchet is
playing a version of hella she's the
ruler of the domain that's thought of as
the Asgardian version of hell I'll
explain what that means in a second just
because the Asgardian version of death
isn't like the normal version of death
it's very very different
speaking of cosmic jeff goldblum
confirmed to be the grandmaster think of
him as like a weird version of the
collector he's another elder of the
universe we're going to see Odin Anthony
Hopkins is coming back Loki of course is
going to be in it Tessa Thompson is
confirmed to be playing Valkyrie
who isn't necessarily going to be the
love interest for Thor but they did
confirm that Natalie Portman is out she
is no longer going to be in Marvel
movies it's kind of like a Gwyneth
Paltrow Pepper Potts thing I don't know
if they left the franchises for the same
reason but the reason that people are
saying Natalie Portman is out is because
she doesn't really want to be in the
movies anymore and they don't really
need her character Kevin Feige issue to
quote the reason he explained that she's
not in the movie is because it's largely
taking place in space she's more of an
earth-based character but when you think
about the core conceit of the character
like the whole reason why they used her
in the first Thor movie you kind of
understand why they don't need her
anymore
they said that they put her in the first
Thor movie because they needed a way to
ground it there was all this weird
Asgardian lore that was very cosmic that
Marvel wasn't really used to doing but
then they did guardians of the galaxy
talking tree talking raccoon and people
totally loved it so they're like oh we
can totally do weird space cosmic stuff
and people will get it now the big one
Karl Urban
is going to be playing scourge he's an
Asgardian warrior that I'll explain in a
second but a lot of people were
wondering about ladies SIF like it's if
gonna be in the movie because Jamie
Alexander is now the star of a TV series
that does like 23 episodes of season so
it's like is she gonna have time to be
in this Thor movie this is what she
tweeted in response so there will be
some SIF in there SIF is still part of
the movies she's not gone forever don't
worry
what about Thanos the director was
joking with James Gunn do I have to put
the purple guy in the floaty chair in my
movie James Gunn's like oh yeah it's a
federal law he has to be on all movies
now so they were joking around but
because there's so much cosmic stuff
happening yes we'll probably see Fano
start doing stuff if you remember during
Avengers age of Ultron all of the Thanos
Infinity Gauntlet stuff came through
Thor's visions so that's why he bailed
on the Avengers at the end of the movie
I have to go back to Asgard and figure
out what these visions mean so that's
what's going to be happening in the
movie amongst other things
the other big story of the movie is
going to be what Loki has been up to
while Thor has been gone he's been
masquerading as Odin Bowden has probably
been stuck at the mercy of hella in hell
she rules over hell her name is hella
you get the idea but this concept art
that Marvel released here is hella
standing in front of a legion of
warriors on Asgard so if you haven't
heard me talk about it before I
described Thor Ragnarok as being like
Thor's version of Winter Soldier think
about what Captain America did in that
movie to shield Asgard has been co-opted
by Loki in the forces of hella Thor has
to clean house so just like Captain
America cleans house it's the outta
Hydra destroys a bunch of buildings
that's probably what's going to be
happening to Asgard in Ragnarok the
whole concept of Ragnarok is about death
and rebirth so there's going to be a
rebirth of Asgardian society we might
even see Thor become king of Asgard
eventually but they might decide not to
do that the really cool thing you may
have noticed this about previous Marvel
movies is that they build in a lot of
plans in case actors Bale they don't
resize contracts so like if Chris Evans
didn't want to be Captain America
anymore they could kill the character
during Avengers infinity war someone
else could take the mantle of Captain
America now that's not happening Chris
Evans has already said he's totally down
to do more Marvel movies but Kevin Feige
has been really
open about how they have a bunch of
different plans in case things don't
work out like if spider-man hadn't have
worked out for Captain America's Civil
War they had a plan to adjust the story
of the movie so that it would still
would have been a really awesome story
they just wouldn't have any spider-man
in it but let me know in the comments
real quick do you think that the Marvel
movies will make Thor king of Asgard
like they have in the comics usually
like in the timeline there's different
versions of Thor depending on which
universe you're in what happens is they
say at some point in the distant future
Odin dies Thor becomes king of Asgard
absorbs Odin's life force and it becomes
the Thor force and he starts to look
kind of like Odin that's where you get
destroyer arm Thor the really old grumpy
Odin sounding version of Thor he starts
to look a lot more like Odin he starts
to act a lot more like Odin but Grand
Master what the hell's going on the way
they're describing him in this Marvel
movie is someone who delights in
manipulating people on a cosmic level
using them as chess pieces so the name
Grand Master makes a little more sense
he's like a chess grandmaster only on a
cosmic level he debuted for the first
time in Avengers number 69 way back in
the late 60s he was the person who
originally possessed the mind gem until
it was taken by Thanos during the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline so what
happens is is eventually the Grandmaster
challenges the cosmic entity death to a
grand game of wits so what might happen
in this movie because I don't know if
they're going to do death and really
hella is the personification of
Asgardian death so she might take that
role in the Marvel Cinematic Universe be
like the stand-in for the cosmic entity
death so he's playing this grand chess
game with all these characters while
Thanos is trying to assemble the
Infinity Gauntlet hella is trying to
conquer Asgard so now it makes sense why
they're titling the movie Ragnarok
because you have all these cosmic forces
swirling around things are going to blow
up in everyone's faces it's going to be
so spectacular and weird
I can't wait Karl Urban scourge who the
hell is scourge is character he's
someone in the comics tied to Loki and
The Enchantress he falls in love with
The Enchantress but gets used as a pawn
by Loki in these big grand schemes so he
sounds like he's going to be something
of an antagonist in the movie so think
of him is a bigger version of curse from
Thor the dark world like a medium bad
character that's not quite as powerful
the big bad who's being played by Cate
Blanchett then you have your chaotic
neutral characters or your true neutral
characters you have Loki you have the
Grandmaster then you have the good
characters like Thor Hulk Valkyrie you
get the idea I think we can all agree
that they have like this a list amazing
cast it's probably to be a great movie
but how do you think they're going to
invoke the Infinity Gauntlet Runner
that's going across the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are we going to see an infinity
gem what piece of the puzzle do you
think that Thanos is going to steal
during the movie because he has at least
one of the gauntlets he doesn't have any
of the gems and I still feel like the
soul gem is going to be in the Doctor
Strange movie we still have the time gem
we still have the soul gem so we might
see the time gem during Thor Ragnarok
but remains to be seen no idea so in
related news there's a bunch of big
stuff that's been happening I'm still
working on a Star Trek trailer video I
meant to do it now but this Thor stop
was so huge that I had to do a video for
it first so be sure to subscribe to get
that there's been news that Michael
Keaton has reassigned on for spider-man
homecoming to be the big villain of that
movie he could be vulture there are a
number of possibilities I've already
done a couple videos about that movie
about Captain America post-credits scene
so I'll put some links in the
description while you guys wait for me
to post my next video
you can click here to learn more about
that spider-man movie and you can click
here to learn all about just to society
on the DC TV shows they're totally doing
just to society thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you